quelques heures après le début des
émeutes à la demande du Président de la
République et de la première ministre
avec le ministre de l'Intérieur nous
avons convoqué les principales
plateformes de réseaux sociaux pour les
rappeler d'abord à leur obligation
devant la loi le retrait des contenus
illicite qui leur sont signalés et la
réponse prompte au réquisition qui leur
sont adressées par l'autorité
administrative et judiciaire nous leur
avons demandé par ailleurs d'exercer la
plus grande vigilance sur les
fonctionnalités de leurs services
susceptibles de porter atteinte à la
sécurité et à l'ordre public le résultat
c'est que ce sont des milliers de
contenus qui ont été retirés des
centaines de comptes qui ont été
supprimés des dizaines de réquisitions
qui ont été traitées le résultat madame
la présente c'est que dans l'heure en
Ille-et-Vilaine dans le Pas-de-Calais en
Haute-Savoie en Pyrénées-Atlantiques
dans les Hauts-de-Seine et dans le
Val-de-Marne des individus ont été
condamnés à des peines de prison pour
s'être livré sur internet à des appels
au meurtre de policiers de gendarmes aux
menaces à des mers ou
aux menaces vis-à-vis